ogni tanto come youtube e ho voglia di
raccontarmi delle cose però queste cose
qua vanno raccontati in modo diretto
senza sceneggiatura senza aver scritto
niente proprio che tutt ed essendo ormai
uno youtube di fama internazionale sono
apparso come avete potuto vedere nel
video di più di bari per esempio mi
riconoscono per strada e parlo a nome di
tutti youtube è una cosa normalissima
poi dipende dalla persona come uno può
reagire a queste cose baci e gente come
denzel washington per esempio che anche
se sta prendendo un caffè al bar non
vuole che gli facciano neanche mezza
fotografia da lontano e poi c'è gente
per esempio che vale i centri
commerciali apposta per rimorchiare in
uk con i suoi scritti in entrambi i casi
dipende dal carattere della persona
il 99 per cento della gente che ferma me
è sempre molto gentile cordiale e
simpaticissima parlottiamo del più e del
meno ci scambiamo il convenevole selphy
di turno
ogni tanto mi chiedono l'autografo ma
quella è una cosa che non ho mai
concepito per che chiede l'autografo arm
e quando c'è tantissima gente a cui
potresti chiederlo infatti quando mi
chiedono di fare un autografo o io
scrivo piero angela di solito sono tutti
i miei coetanei ma ogni tanto mi fermano
anche i ragazzini più giovani e devo
dire che sono molto gentili cioè quando
sono su internet sono dei maiali di
merda che dovresti sgozzare a testa in
giù per fare del bacon invece di persone
hanno delle maniere incredibili mamme
complimenti cazzo li avete addestrati
alla perfezione è questo come dicevo nel
99 per cento dei casi
io vorrei parlarvi di quell'uno per
cento di quelle persone che se sono
sempre gentili cordiali e simpaticissime
però che come dire non sono molto
avvezzi a leggere la stanza al capire
quando non magari non è il caso di
chiedere determinate cose o di una di
una certa maniera di levarsi dai
in quel momento ma comunque
comunque sempre in modo molto gentile e
uno cosa può fare se non berci su
oggi vi voglio parlare del ragazzo del
treno
io nell'arco di un anno prendo un numero
abbastanza alto di treni di solito per
gli spettacoli di stendhal e quindi
capita spesso che in stazione mi fermi
perché c'è un sacco di gente quindi
capita che ci sia quello che vi
riconosce è molto più raro invece che mi
fermino dentro al vagone quando il treno
in movimento
c'è stata una volta in cui io e la mia
ragazza martina stavamo andando ad uno
spettacolo purtroppo ci avevano dati i
biglietti vicini ma staccati nel senso
era nello stesso le nella stessa lettera
il problema è che eravamo se quando c'è
4 col tavolo a sinistra e 4 col tavola a
destra con in mezzo il corridoio
ecco io ero seduto nel tavolo a sinistra
e lei era seduta del tavolo destra
eravamo a fianco ma in due tavoli
diversi
quindi ero con tre perfetti sconosciuti
leira con tre perfetti sconosciuti noi
devo dire che non siamo molto socievoli
come persone non noi in generale sul
treno perché ognuno si fa i cazzi suoi
a malapena ci si scambia la stessa area
ci dà proprio fastidio infatti stanno
tutti a guardare il cellulare tu non sei
seduto con delle persone si è seduto con
delle attaccature per i capelli e così
in silenzio per un'oretta il telo e
pieno ed è una di quelle rare volte in
cui è completamente silenzioso ma non è
un problema a un certo punto vedo dal
fondo del corridoio un ragazzo che si
avvicina non togliendo me lo sguardo di
dosso c'è un problema però nonostante
questa cosa sia la norma nel senso che
mica mi fermano tutti i giorni però
capita spessissimo per strada non solo
con abituato mi viene l'ansia e inizio
sull'area c dove iniziò un odore di
costine alla griglia che non vi dico e
quindi arriva spedito questo ragazzo che
mi fissa
immaginatevi nel silenzio più totale di
un vagone pieno di sconosciuti ad un
volume di voce anche bello sostenuto che
dice ma tu sei yotobi io lo guardo
spaventato dico perché poi cerco di
parlare piano io così loro magari si
rendono conto e disco a bilancia a
mixare l'audio giusto ed è lì che con la
coda dell'occhio ho visto una marea di
biclette praticamente tutta la gente che
avevo intorno alzato lo sguardo e si è
girato verso di me che poi io ero seduto
dalla parte del corridoio e quindi vedo
anche delle facce che spuntano in
diagonale di seguì davanti che quindi
figura di altro che odore di costine
proprio
gli ata mista che non ti dico e come se
non bastasse in questa situazione
drammatica non è che scambiamo due
parole no fa la cosa peggiore che poteva
fare in quel momento si presenta con un
blocco note di se non mi vuoi farmi un
autografo a questo volume di voce e non
è che posso dire sicurezza equa nel
controllino al biglietto magari no
ovviamente siccome era comunque molto
gentili dico certo va bene mentre la
gente mi guarda ti faccio l'autografo e
lui siccome ha visto che io era
abbastanza disponibile cos'ha fatto
ha tirato fuori il cellulare per farsi
una foto ma che scusare non è che
potresti salutarmi il mio amico
gianfranco guarda già un frase premi
quali mani un bel vocale e gianfranco mi
raccomando parla bene che c'è il tè non
si sente bene gianfranco e quindi o sono
in treno in mezzo agli sguardi
disconosciute con martina che si copriva
così che non mi voleva guardare con un
cellulare di un altro che parlò ad un
perfetto sconosciuto dicendo e
gianfranco già un salutone dagli otto
vip e lì per lì fermi che poi sono
sicuro ci fosse anche tensioni da parte
sua nel senso deve avere anche un po di
coraggio a venire a parlare a me oa
chiunque altro però poi sai come finisce
la storia che tu ti riprendi il cielo è
di ciao ciao grazie mille e io invece
rimango co sti stronzi che continuano a
guardarmi qualcuno soprattutto quelli
magari della mia 30 intorno alla
trentina d'anni che non sanno che io sia
che si mettono a guardare sul cellulare
e io me ne accorgo porca di una
se tu guardi con cellulare poi continui
a guardare mai poi cellulare poi me poi
il cellulare poi metto il cellulare ho
sputato tutto il tavolo ag e schivo
quindi io vi voglio bene perché grazie a
voi ho un lavoro che mi piace fare e
altrimenti non sapremmo fare un cazzo e
sarei finito sotto un ponte a chiedere
l'elemosina
grazie per avermi salvato da una vita di
merda però impariamo a leggere le
situazioni per l'amore di dio
impariamo a vedere se si può nel caso di
chiedere una foto gianfranco
[Musica]